nombreux sont ceux qui aujourd'hui
encore à 6000 francophonie à
colonialisme le français était parlée
dans tout l'empiré il est encore bien
sûr et singulièrement en afrique et dans
certains pays il peut servir de ciment
politique c'est le cas de la côte
d'ivoire où son talent et geneviève moll
et bernard ap
la côte d'ivoire 8 million et demi
d'habitants soixante ethnies cinq
grandes langues nationales mais un
ferment de l'unité le français langue
officielle
ça veut dire que les actes de la vie
publique
l'administration l'école
et
tout ce qui est documents écrits public
tout cela se fait en français
6 30 % des adultes seulement par le
français 80% des enfants sont
aujourd'hui scolarisées dans cette
langue mais que se passe t-il avant
l'école
les analyses à
elsa il ne parle pas français quelle
langue il va pas les vilains le dioula
est-ce que vous avez tous par les
français il qui sépare les français
tu parles de penser au reste il faut
pour parler tu parles les deux si on
parle tout le temps france est belle les
enfants comprennent pas la langue qui
seront pas parler la langue critères
donc on parle plus la langue et c'était
pour recevoir le long oui c'est très
important chez nous pourquoi parce que
quand on ne parle pas la langue arrivé
au village on te traite de
enfin je sais pas combien de temps si
oui il faut parler la langue
on se moque de toi
dans l'état actuel de l'enseignement la
pratique des langues maternelles
handicap les jeunes enfants dans
l'apprentissage du français
l'enfant des difficultés à l'école parce
que lorsqu'elles enfants dont en zone
rurale par exemple va à l'école on le
prend comme si jusque là il a parlé
français aux îles à sa langue maternelle
et cela fait un blocage un blocage un
nouvel apprentissage du français dont
nous pensons que la connaissance des
langues parlées par les enfants doivent
contribuer à l'aide à l'amélioration du
français
il a mis son coeur
c'est le mur 1
pourquoi détruire
et voyez on ne croira
à ces difficultés s'ajoutent une
surcharge des classes qui rend encore
plus malaisée l'enseignement de la
langue française et en appauvri le
niveau malgré cela et grâce à la
scolarisation à outrance le français
explose devient langue littéraire et
langue de culture même pour les parents
qui le pratiquent peu
mais vous avez senti une évolution du
public est ce que vous avez de plus en
plus de jeunes ivoiriens qui viennent
lire oui il ya surtout les pins mais
commence à être et ils sont plus
intéressés par la lecture surtout de
leurs enfants ils achètent pour leurs
enfants ils veulent que les enfants
s'intéressent à la bêtise je pense que
le fond est un bel avenir ici la langue
nationale viendra mais certainement pas
pour demain il faut être réaliste
ainsi dans ce pays où aucune des langues
nationales ne peut prendre le pas sur
les autres sans risque politique
l'espace francophone reste donc le lieu
privilégié de communication ou un espace
ronco